okay can i step it up
can we can we can we try something
harder
looking around most people i think i've
got it um it's not that it's not that
difficult actually that's sort of more
like a warm up
for this this is the real kind of
question okay so
how's it different how is it the same um
it's the same in that i'm still after a
specific coefficient
okay but it's different in that now i'm
considering a product of two
binomials gross okay now by the way
that's part of why
these numbers are not as huge okay
but the press is going to be similar
with a little bit of complexity advil
okay
so before i start writing this thing out
okay um i'm still going to
start off in much the same way i am
going to have to write an expansion out
but the difference is this time i am
actually going to need every time the
expansion to
see enough of the pattern okay now i'm
going to call this one
my red expansion and i'm going to call
this one my green one because they're
going to get really confusing
really fast in a second okay so let's
start by actually doing the extension
this one to the power of four this one
to the power of three
okay let's do the red one first right
nice big square brackets and every bit
of the
um of each term we should include right
so the first term
it's by maybe your coefficient will be
just four choose not
right and then how much do i have on
each
of these terms well i'm going to have
four of the first one
and i'm going to have none of the second
one
okay so good now next term along
everything increments up or down
accordingly okay is this the right one
yeah that's plus okay so just
watch out in a second i'm going to get
the minus sign for later on but for now
i don't need to worry about it
okay then four choose two
four choose three
and my last one four choose four
oops sorry skip the number
okay is that all right so it's the power
four that's why there are five terms
so far so good but that's multiplied by
this other expansion which has less
terms but it's still kind of gross
big square brackets is the power three
so the royal pascal's triangle i'm in is
the third row
right so three choose naught x to the
three and this time i got the minus sign
so include it okay minus one on x
i've got no lots of it in the first turn
okay
then it keeps going
three choose two
and the last one
okey-dokey now in order to see what's
going on here
and see what's uh what's actually going
to be useful to me to work out what the
coefficient of that term is
let's just do a little bit of
simplifying here um get rid of some of
the
you know you've got these different x
terms which actually interact with each
other okay
so the first one and four g is not
actually anything choose naught
and anything choose itself we know
that's equal to one okay so i'm going to
start to drop that off
try and tidy this up a little bit our
first term will be x to the four
right then i'll have four choose one now
i've got
three lots of x and then i've got to
divide by x once right so my
actual power up here will be x to the
two
yep next one four choose
two and the x squared and 1 over x
squared cancel out exactly okay
so it's just 4 choose 2. right now 4
choose 3 how many have i got are those
well i've got 1 lot of x and i have to
divide by 3 lots of x
so i've got 1 over x squared
and then my last term over here
1 over x to the 4.
okay so it does start to look a little
bit neater once you get down to it
down here again three choose not that's
just one
x cube no lots of this so that's what
i've got there
okay next one over three choose
one now watch out for your signs okay
i've got an x squared and then i have to
divide by an x and i also have this
minus sign right so what am i going to
get
that's minus 1 over x
right
is that okay
yes wait sorry no wrong way
minus x i'm ahead of myself okay to the
next term
three choose two
here this is what i meant so i've got
one by x and then i'm dividing by two
um but that minus one it's squares so
it's a positive
and i've got one over x
that's better okay last one along three
choose three
is just one and i've got no lots of this
and that minus one is going to go three
times so i'm going to end up with a
negative so i've got minus one over x
cubed okay we got there
right now what am i after i like the
coefficient of x
okay now when you multiply out right
you're going to get a whole bunch of
terms
uh in fact you're going to get well i've
got five times here and four times here
so i would get 20 terms out at the end
and then i have to do some simplifying
okay but out of those 20
which ones would like be interested in
right only the ones that give me a
single x at the end
okay so for instance if i take this x to
the 4
it will only produce an x when it
matches up with one specific term
out of the green series right which term
does it need to match up with
yeah the very last one over here yeah
so they sort of have to pick up okay
in the same way this x squared term here
what does it have to match up to
to get an x well it's going to have to
match up to this one and only this one
right so this x squared and this one
over x
they're going to connect as well okay
now this this is just a constant okay so
which one will it match up to
where it has an x so you can actually
see it's just i'm going one at a time
right
so this nothing is going to line up with
here
and this one over x squared you can
follow the pattern it's going to
link up to that x cubed
okay now at this stage even though i've
got one left over term here
it's one over x to the four right
there's no term in the green series that
it could match up with
to get an x right because what would it
need it would need an x to the five
wouldn't it which i which i don't have
okay so therefore now that i've got
these
one two three four paired terms i'm
after just the coefficient okay
so the coefficient of x
will be equal to now just to help us one
little bit more so that next time you
don't have to have all these numbers of
crazy
arrows flying around right i can
generalize this a little better by
calling this say
let's call all of the terms here you
know term n okay
and we'll call this one i can't call it
t so call the next letter alone
i'll call them u m all right
so what have i got um this x to the four
right depending on the way that you
write it i'm gonna call it
term zero right or its coefficient
rather
it has to line up with zero one 2 3.
right so that's u 3.
yep those two have to they're going to
multiply out
then i move over 1 here
and here i move 1 back right so this
will be term 1 and then u
two yes turn
two u one turn
three sorry i missed one
no it's okay zero and i'm out of terms
that's it okay there are my one two
three four pairs
okay so now that i've identified them i
just want the numbers for each one
okay so here i've got one and minus one
here i'm going to have four choose one
and what does it line up to three choose
two right
next one along turn two that's up here
so four
choose two and that lines up with
three choose one and don't forget
it also has a minus sign there hi
um from that minus there okay so watch
out for that
and lastly four choose three
three choose north which was just one
actually we already knew that
okay so now i can evaluate that
so there's the coefficient at the end
okay so you can see
this was a little more um this is a
little more work actually a fair bit
more work trying to line up the terms
but once you see what's going on and
that you're moving forward here and
backward here
that allows you to produce this thing
can you see how orderly the coefficients
are
and they just build quite um in quite a
structured way okay
so it's quite pretty